بعد عشره ايام من الاشتباكات المسلحه التي
تدور راحها في السودان المانيا حالها كحال
دول اجنبيه عده سارعت لاجلاء رعاياها وقد
اجلت بالفعل
313 من رعاياها على متن ثلاث طائرات من
سلاح الجو الالماني وبمشاركه اكثر من الف
جندي الحكومه الفرنسيه بدورها قالت انها
اجلت
388 من رعاياها وعلقت عمل سفارتها
بالخرطوم بسبب الوضع الامني الحالي اما
ايطاليا فاجلت تسعه عشر من رعاياها من
بورتسودان الى مصر بالتنسيق مع السلطات
المصريه في الاثناء افادت النرويج وهولندا
والدنمارك باجلاء مواطنيها من السودان عبر
جيبوتي اليابان من جانبها اعلنت ارسال
ثلاث طائرات الى جيبوتي لنقل مواطنيها من
السودان هذا
وقد اجلت اربع طائرات تابعه لسلاح الجو
الملكي الاردني عبر مطار بورت سودان
343 مواطنا اردنيا ورعاي دول عربيه
واجنبيه بدورها اعلنت الخارجيه المصريه عن
اجلال
436 من مواطنيها في السودان والبالغ عددهم
نحو عشره الاف